واحد من اكثر سباقات الانتخابات النصفيه
حتى هذا العام في الولايات المتحده يحدث
هنا في ولايه جورجيا
فالمنافسه على اشدها بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين على منصب حاكم الولايه
ومقعدي مجلس الشيوخ الذي قد تتحدث السيطره
عليه في السباق بين عضو المجلس الحالي
الديمقراطي رافاييل غرناك ومنافسه
الجمهوري هيرش الواقر لهذا يرى محللون ان
جورجيا اصبحت ساحه انتخابيه حاسمه
لثلاثه اسباب اولا الجمهوريون بحاجه ماسه
للحصول عليها ليكون اغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
ثانيا تتجه جورجيا نحو الديمقراطيه مثل
ولايات اخرى في الجنوب مع كل الجمهوريين
واخيرا تبدو جورجيا مثل بقيه الامه وما
يحدث فيها قد يظهر لنا ما سيحدث على
الصعيد الوطني
في انتخابات عام 2020 تحولت الولايه
الجمهوريه الى اللون الازرق رمز
الديمقراطيين بعدما فاز جو بيدن باصوات
مجمعه الانتخابيه وخسر الجمهوريون مقعديها
في مجلس الشيوخ ما اعطى الديمقراطيين فرصه
في احدى معاقل الجمهوريين يريدون الحفاظ
عليها
الاربع سنين
الجمهوري لحاكم جمهوري ولكن لمجلس الشيوخ
ديموقراطي لذلك ممكن انه جورجيا تروح يا
ديمقراطيين يجمهوريين
لكن المهمه امام الديمقراطيين ستكون صعبه
بعد تعديل الولايه لقانونها الانتخابي
الذي يفرض قيودا جديده على التصويت قالت
وزاره العدل انها تهدف الى حرمان او تقليص
حق التصويت للامريكيين من اصول الافريقيه
الذين دعموا انتخاب ايضا وفوز
الديمقراطيين في مقعدي مجلس
الشيوخذه
احد مشكلات القانون الجديد انه يقيد عدد
الاماكن التي يمكنك فيها التصويت ببطاقات
الاختراع الغيابي ويقيد مقدار الوقت ذلك
وكانت بطاقات الاقتراع الغيابيه هذه اكثر
الديمقراطيه في العامين الماضيين لذلك
بشكل اساسي سيؤدي هذا الى القضاء على بعض
المكاسب التي حققها الديمقراطيون في
جورجيا في الانتخابات القليله الماضيه حيث
تحقق اداء جيدا في انتخابات الاعاده
التي ينسب اليها الفضل بفوز الديمقراطيين
في الولايه الحاكمه الجمهوريه الحالي
كامبا وهما يتنافسان على المنصب للمره
الثانيه بعد انتخابات عام 2018 بعد خسارته
مقعدائه الولايه في مجلس الشيوخ في
الانتخابات السابقه
يسعى بقوه الى استعاده احد المقعدين من
الديمقراطيين فيما تشتد المنافسه على منصب
حاكم الولايه الذي يعمل الديمقراطيون
للفوز به ما يزيد من احتدام المعركه
الانتخابيه ويجعل جورجيا الساحه
الانتخابيه الحاسمه حسين الطاوض العربيه
من مدينه اطلنطا في ولايه جورجيا